c'est la
prère donner son sang n'est pas un acte
anodin il peut sauver des vies la
semaine dernière l'Établissement
Français du sî de France organisa une
collecte dans les locaux de la mairie de
Trapp sur les civières personnel de la
commune et trapiste pour Habiba c'était
la première fois une expérience qui
s'est bien passé et qu'elle soit réitér
à
l'avenir je suis ven don un de sang pour
qui ont besoin tant qu'on est en bonne
santé je préfère donner aux gens qui ont
besoin les gens qui ont des accidents
sur la route des maladies grave là je
suis venue en janvier mais c'est dommage
qu'il viennent pas plus souvent je suis
donneuse bénévole normalement donc
depuis des années DEP de 60 dons déjà
dans ma carte globules rouges plaquettes
plasma des dons indispensables pour
permettre la guérison de maladies comme
la leucémie ou la drpanocytose une
maladie génétique de l'hémoglobine qui
nécessite une transfusion sanguine par
semaine dès le plus jeune âge des dons
qui permettent aussi de donner des
traitements de qualité aux patients
globalement depuis le début de l'année
sur les Yvelines ou sur le secteur dont
j'ai responsabilité mais essentiellement
les ivelines ça se passe très bien parce
que nous sommes au-dessus d'un
objectif plus particulièrement nous
avons connu un un mois de de septembre
et d'octobre pas très bon et là cette
semaine est pas bonne du tout puisque
grosso modo quand on attend sans donneur
d'habitude il y en a 80 15 qui se
présente et là on est plutôt au niveau
de 70 en île-defance 1700 dons par jour
sont nécessaires 4 dons maximum par an
pour les femmes et 6 pour les hommes
mais les trapistes eux ont été généreux
ce jour-là 73 donneurs ont répondu
présent au lieu des 60
attendus